[Musik]
Tatort Deutschland die crime Doku von
Bild
hallo Leute hier sind wieder Toni und
Mirko und wir haben heute was Neues also
keinen neuen aus der aktuellen
zeitstammenden Fall sondern ein von 1924
aber es gibt ein Motiv dass wir in allen
Fällen bei Tatort Deutschland bisher
noch nicht hatten Mirko was gab es da
alles Mord aus Habgier Mord um ein
anderes Verbrechen zu vertuschen Mord in
einem politischen Machtkampf wie bei
Cäsar oder Ramses und vielleicht bei
Caspar Hauser oder den Mord aus Rache
wie in Überlingen ja und Mord aus
Sadismus und aus krankem verlangen wie
beim Vampir von Düsseldorf
also wenn man das also aufzählt was
machen wir hier eigentlich beruflich da
darf man wirklich nicht zu lange drüber
nachdenken alle Lockerheit jetzt mal
beiseite beim Verbrechen von heute gab
es nichts dergleichen wir stürzen uns in
die Fallakten von Nathan Leopold und
Richard low Mirko vorhang auf für zwei
völlig Kranke Typen
Richard Lope und Nathan Leopard Junior
sind zwei Studenten der University of
Chicago aus reichen Familien in der Zeit
in der diese Geschichte beginnt sind sie
19 und 18 Jahre alt im Frühjahr 1924
diskutieren die beiden ob ihnen das
perfekte Verbrechen gelingen würde was
ihnen vor schwebt ist ein Mord dazu muss
man sagen dass Morde damals an der
Tagesordnung waren wir können uns immer
einen kurzen Einschub denn unsere
unfassbare Geschichte heute die spielt
in der Zeit von Prohibition und Mafia
1920 hatten 36 Bundesstaaten der USA den
18 Zusatz der Verfassung gebilligt und
sich damit dem Verbot von Alkohol
angeschlossen für das Gesetz gab es
gewiss ehrenwerte Gründe aber schon bald
zeigte sich die Herstellung von Alkohol
und der Ausschank wanderten in den
Untergrund und damit übernahmen Gangster
Bosse fast von einem Tag auf den anderen
die Kontrolle über Milliarden Einnahmen
infolgedessen stieg die Zahl der
Verbrechen allein von 1920 bis 1921 um
24% an die organisierte Kriminalität
geht die prächtig
mafia-bossen wie Al Capone gelang es
eine regelrechte Alkoholindustrie
aufzubauen und sie nutzten die
Illegalität des Trinkens indem sie
völlig überhöhte Preise forderten wir
befinden uns also in einer Zeit in der
die Polizei und ihre Mord Ermittler
eigentlich genug zu tun haben denn man
kennt ja aus zahlreichen Filmen oder
Büchern die Reviere des organisierten
Verbrechens waren blutig umstritten
Mirko wenn wir jetzt über einen Mordfall
aus dieser Zeit sprechen dann sehe ich
das irgendwie gedanklich auch alles in
schwarz weiß ja das passt glaube ich
ganz gut wir sehen also zwei junge
Studenten in den 20er Jahren vor uns die
sich für besonders schlau halten nicht
ganz so unrecht übrigens denn Leopold
hat im Alter seit 19 Jahren bereits das
College abgeschlossen und studiert Jura
an der University of Chicago er spricht
fünf Sprachen und ist ein Experte auf
dem Gebiet der Vogelkunde sein Freund
Lob ist der jüngste Absolvent in der
Geschichte der University of Michigan
beide leben in Kenwood einer
wohlhabenden Gegend im Süden Chicagos
ich habe mir hier am rechnermann ein
Bild von den beiden aufgemacht also wenn
man sich die anguckt das sind so richtig
reiche
sorry dass ich so ehrlich sage aber
Schnösel Klugscheißer Typen jetzt auch
nicht unattraktiv aber bestimmt ziemlich
arrogant so gegelte Haare feine Anzüge
fester ein bisschen selbstverliebter
Blick wie sich zeigt haben sich die
beiden in einen gewagtes gedankenbild
hineingesteigert sie halten sich für
sogenannte Übermenschen das passt zum
schnügelbild ist aber ein durchaus ernst
gemeintes Konstruktes Philosophen
Nietzsche aus dessen Sicht ist es die
Aufgabe des Menschen einen Typus
hervorzubringen der höher entwickelt ist
als er selbst und zwar von Seiten der
Intelligenz der körperlichen Fitness und
der Moral
letztendlich sollen Übermenschen die
Menschheit auf die nächsthöchste Stufe
bringen
einerseits interessant aber andererseits
irgendwie auch krank und hast du absolut
Recht denn die beiden steigern sich in
den Gedanken hinein einen perfekten
unentdeckten straflosen Mord zu begehen
ohne irgendein weiteres Motiv dabei
schon bald haben sie das Grundgerüst
eines Plans entwickelt darin enthalten
eine Entführung ein Mord Säure ein
ablagerort und sie suchen ein Opfer dass
man sowas mal theoretisch
durchdiskutiert das kann ich mir ja noch
vorstellen und finde ich irgendwo auch
noch okay vor allem mit dem
Hintergedanken dass die beiden Jura
studieren also so ein Interesse ist da
vielleicht einfach da für die
juristische Lage in jungen Jahren malt
man sich dann auch vielleicht so in den
Bankraub oder irgendwie sowas aus kenne
ich selbst aber
wer macht sowas schon in echt am 21 mai
1924 locken Leopold und Lob dessen
Cousin Bobby Franks in einen gemieteten
Wagen sie töten ihn veretzen die Leiche
und stecken sie in ein Rohr
versehentlich lassen Sie eine Brille am
Tatort zurück und sie schicken einen
anonymen Brief mit einer
Lösegeldforderung von 10.000 Dollar an
die Eltern des Jungen das ist die
Kurzfassung Leopold und Lob denken die
Leiche sei gut versteckt sie glauben
auch dass sie keine verräterischen
Spuren zurückgelassen haben aber all das
stimmt genauso wenig wie ihre Annahme
dass sie über Menschen sind denn schon
kurz darauf entdecken Eisenbahnarbeiter
die Leiche am Fundort wird außerdem die
Brille entdeckt und die soll sich noch
als wichtiger reisen die Brille sieht
gewöhnlich aus die Gläser sind rund
eingefasst aber die Scharniere sind eine
besondere Konstruktion die so bisher
erst drei Chicago verkauft wurde
das findet staatsanwalt Robert Crowe
zusammen mit der Polizei heraus er führt
jetzt die Ermittlungen es ist super
spannend die Berichte von damals zu
lesen da löst sich auch nämlich auf wem
eigentlich diese Brillen so gehört haben
diese super besonderen
Spezialanfertigung eine der seltenen
Brillen wurde an eine Frau verkauft eine
weitere an einen Mann der sich länger im
Ausland aufgehalten hat und bei den
Ermittlungen sozusagen ja dann auch raus
ist und die dritte die gehört nächsten
Leopold und der wird zur Sache befragt
wobei er zunächst nicht dringend
verdächtigt wird denn warum sollte ein
milliardär-sohn läppische 10.000 Dollar
erpressen wollen
aber Robert Cro wird misstrauisch
Leopold erzählt Axel zuckend er sei nun
mal ein anerkannter Vogelkundler die
Brille sei wohl bei einer Expedition aus
der Jackentasche gefallen
in der Gegend in der die Leiche gefunden
wurde sah er öfter um Vögel zu
beobachten außerdem habe er ein Alibi er
und Lob sein in der Nacht zusammen
unterwegs gewesen und in seinem roten
Auto der Marco Willis night durch die
Stadt gefahren sie hätten schließlich in
einem Park etwas getrunken und Mädchen
getroffen da dies aber keinen Sex
wollten seien sie schließlich nach Hause
gefahren ich kann mir richtig gut
vorstellen wie Staatsanwalt Cro
misstrauisch wird als in dieser Schnösel
Bubi so alt glatt und arrogant seine
Geschichten erzählt aber jetzt ist
Schluss mit Gelaber abwechselnd und
getrennt werden Leopold und Lob Verhör
technisch in die Mangel genommen zum
Teil 24 Stunden am Stück zwischendurch
kommt der Chauffeur der Familie Leopold
ins Präsidium er wurde von dessen Vater
geschickt er will die Jungs entlasten
sie hätten nicht in der Nähe des
Fundorts der Leiche sein können weil
Nathans Auto in der Garage stand ja
hilft aber alles nichts als erster
gesteht Globe vernehmungsleiter Cro
konfrontiert danach Nelson Leopold mit
den Einzelheiten und der gesteht jetzt
auch schiebt aber die Schuld seinem
Freund zu die Beweislast wird mit jeder
Stunde erdrückend da die Handschrift auf
dem Brief mit der Lösegeldforderung ist
von Leopold der Brief ist mit seiner
Schreibmaschine geschrieben und nach den
Geständnissen hören die beiden
Wichtigtuer gar nicht mehr auf zu reden
und so findet sich nach und nach der
genaue Tatablauf in den Protokollen
Mirko am Vormittag des 21 mai 1924 nach
monatelanger Planung schreibt Leopold
den Erpresserbrief die beiden leihen
unter falschen Namen ein graues Auto
Leopold und Lob Wissen zu diesem
Zeitpunkt immer noch nicht wen sie töten
würden sie fahren ziellos durch die
Gegend und sehen dann Richard Cousin
Bobby auf dem Fußweg Mirko lass uns
diesen Moment mal bitte einfrieren
wir halten das Auto mitten in der Fahrt
an und auf dem Fußgängerweg bleibt Bobby
Franks in seiner Bewegung stehen erst 14
Jahre alt von Fotos kennen wir ihn als
niedlichen Jungen mit dunklen längeren
und lockigen Haaren er trägt lange
Strümpfe und eine nickerbockerhose die
damals so typisch war vielleicht hat er
auch seine graue Wolljacke an er ahnt in
diesem Moment überhaupt nichts Böses
pfeift vor sich hin oder hat gerade ein
Stein zur Seite gekickt
neben ihm halten sein Cousin Richard und
dessen Kumpel Nathan in einem grauen
Auto an
Perspektivwechsel auf die beiden
nächsten und Richard schauen sich an
entscheiden sich in diesem Moment völlig
spontan das ist unser Opfer den bringen
wir um
jetzt lassen wir das Geschehen wieder
laufen
sobald sie Bobby ins Auto gelockt haben
geschieht der Mord Richard der auf der
Rückbank sitzt schlägt den Jungen mit
einem Stemmeisen bewusstlos dann
ersticken sie ihn mit einem Lappen den
sie dem Kind in den Mund stecken
sie fahren zu den Feuchtwiesen nahe dem
Lake Michigan und kaufen unterwegs
Hotdogs und Bier die eiskalt kann man
bitte sein ich meine das ist Familie und
ein Kind und die beiden haben nichts
besseres zu tun als noch schnell Hotdogs
und Bier holen sie gießen Säure über
sein Gesicht und schieben die Leiche in
ein Abflussrohr das in einem Graben
unter den Bahngleisen herauslockt
in dem Gefühl geht navens Brille
verloren aber das kümmert die jungen
Männer in diesem Moment nicht ein
fataler Fehler nach dem Geständnissen
ist der Mitteilungsdrang der Mörder groß
sie helfen mit Hinweisen bei der
Spurensuche und sie schildern Detail
verliebt den Ablauf der Tat
Ermittler Cro erinnert sich später die
beiden hätten gerade zu stolz auf ihre
Aktivitäten gewirkt
Cro informiert die Öffentlichkeit und
kündigt dabei an für Gerechtigkeit zu
sorgen und fordert die Todesstrafe
obwohl wir uns mitten in den Wirren der
Prohibition und Bandenkriege befinden
also jeden Tag super viel los da kennen
die Zeitungen ab jetzt Monate lang kein
anderes Thema mehr zumal die Mörder
kräftig mitmischen und aus dem Gefängnis
heraus mit Details ihre Taten auch noch
angeben kein Wunder also dass auch der
Prozess zum Spektakel wird die Familie
Lobs engagiert den 67-Jährigen
Rechtsanwalt Clarence Darrow als
Verteidiger
einen erbitterten Gegner der Todesstrafe
in der Öffentlichkeit wird erwartet dass
er auf Freispruch wegen
Unzurechnungsfähigkeit plädieren würde
aber überraschenderweise bekennen sich
die beiden Angeklagten auf seinen Rat
hin schuldig das macht nach dem Recht in
Illinois die Berufung von Geschworenen
überflüssig damit wollte die
Verteidigung Todesurteile durch
aufgebrachte Geschworene abwenden
aufgebracht konnte man angesichts dieses
Falles schon sein ich meine nächsten
Leopold hat jetzt auf die Frage hin was
er von der Tat denke ich gesagt das
schert mich nicht besonders er verglich
den Mord an Baumi damit wie man einen
Käfer aufspießt ja das ist wirklich
unfassbar abgebrüht Toni
aber andererseits waren sich die
Beobachter damals einig dass Verteidiger
darro das beste Plädoyer seiner Laufbahn
hielt er argumentierte leidenschaftlich
gegen die Todesstrafe im Allgemeinen und
verteidigte die Angeklagten als
Minderjährige die sich nicht über die
Konsequenzen ihres Handelns klar waren
aber waren die mit 18 und 19 nicht schon
erwachsen nee nee Toni damer als und
auch noch lange danach galt das 21
lebensjahr als die Grenze
daraus Strategie jedenfalls geht auf der
zuständige Richter verurteilte Leopold
und Lob zu einer lebenslangen
Freiheitsstrafe für den Mord und zu
weiteren 99 Jahren Gefängnis für die
Entführung BAM ab in den Knast mit euch
ja erstmal landen beide head
correctional Center das ist ein großes
Gefängnis im Südwesten von Chicago
später werden sie nach state will
verlegt dass nur eine Viertelstunde mit
dem Auto entfernt und hier hat der Fall
noch ein tödliches Nachspiel 1936
12 Jahre nach dem Mord an Bobby Franks
wird Lob im Alter von 30 Jahren von
einem Zellen genossen namens James Bay
mit einem Rasiermesser getötet
day kann später glaubhaft machen dass
Lob versucht habe ihn in den Waschräumen
zu vergewaltigen und er folgliche
Notwehr gehandelt habe
Nathan Leopold zieht diese Darstellung
später im Zweifel und wird dabei
unterstützt von einem katholischen
Gefängnisseelsorger ihre These in
Wahrheit habe day den getöteten Lob
bedrängt und ihn im Handgemenge getötet
was wurde aus Leopold der wurde 1958 auf
Bewährung entlassen da hatte er 33 Jahre
abgesessen
im gleichen Jahr veröffentlichte er
seine Memoiren unter dem Titel Life Plus
ninety nine years also lebenslang plus
99 Jahre
er zog nach Puerto Rico um unbestürzt zu
sein er heiratete eine verwitwetete
Floristin und starb schließlich 1971 mit
66 Jahren an einem Herzinfarkt das ist
wirklich ein ganz ganz schwieriger Fall
ich finde es auch schwierig ihn
irgendwie in Worte zu fassen mit welchem
Gefühl man da jetzt so rausgeht ja und
er hat auch seine Spuren in der
künstlerischen Welt hinterlassen der die
Geschichte von Leopold und Lob wurde
mindestens dreimal verfilmt unter
anderem als Cocktail für eine Leiche von
Alfred Hitchcock und es gab
Theaterstücke und Romane ja und wenn man
sich durch die Berichte kämpft sind da
auch zwei wirklich heikle Punkte gewesen
an dem Fall Lob und Leopold kam aus
jüdischen Familien auch wenn Sie das
Judentum nicht praktiziert haben es war
also stets mit antisemitischen
Vorurteilen oder Deutungen des Falls zu
rechnen laut Zeitzeugen befürchtete man
sowas zumindest in der jüdischen
Gemeinde Chicagos und in der Recherche
habe ich auch von Priestern gewesen die
eben diesen Fall für antisemitische
Hetze benutzt haben deshalb betonten
auch viele dass das Opfer ebenfalls Jude
gewesen sei um sich blöd gesagt vor
dieser Propaganda zu schützen und der
zweite heiklepunkt du wirst viele
Stellen finden wo es um das Verhältnis
der beiden Mörder geht mindestens Lob
galt als schwul die beiden mithin als
Paar und das war in der damaligen Zeit
für manche ja schon an sich etwas
verbrecherisches ja das hat sich ja auch
viele Jahrzehnte später noch nicht
geändert
ja im Fall über denen man wirklich noch
lange sinnieren kann aber besonders
schrecklich finde ich die Arroganz mit
der die beiden aufgetreten sind und mit
der Sie diese Tat geplant haben das
finde ich irgendwie besonders
widerwärtig denn beide sind ja
offensichtlich zwei sehr privilegierte
junge Männer die ein Leben führen können
wie es sich viele zu dieser Zeit
überhaupt nicht vorstellen können oder
nicht leisten können und das führt bei
beiden offenbar zur Vorstellung dass sie
ungestraft einem anderen Menschen das
Leben nehmen könnten ich glaube dass das
genau der Knackpunkt ist dass die beiden
so privilegiert sind und eigentlich die
haben keine Sorgen andere träumen von
von ihrem Leben von den Möglichkeiten
die sie haben und ich glaube ihnen ist
es auch gar nicht so bewusst wie gut es
ihnen geht weil das für sie alles
selbstverständlich ist so was was haben
die versorgen um was müssen sie sich
kümmern um gar nichts und dann denken
die sich wir sind so geil wer soll uns
überhaupt irgendwas anhaben können
trotzdem wollen sie das natürlich
versteckt machen also wollen das ja
nicht in aller Öffentlichkeit tun aber
sie gehen davon aus dass sie aufgrund
ihrer Situation ihrer Lebenssituation
ihrer Intelligenz Ihre finanziellen
Möglichkeiten natürlich auch und der
damit einhergehenden Arroganz
einfach einen Marktbeginn ohne dass es
jemand mitbekommt oder ohne dass sie
dafür irgendwann zur Rechenschaft
gezogen werden das ist schon wirklich
sehr sehr widerwärtig das Konstrukt des
Übermenschen scheint ihn ja wirklich
sehr gut gefallen zu haben und auf mich
wirkt das Ganze so
in ihrer ekelhaften Art und Weise
wollten sie sich durch den Mord beweisen
oder sozusagen bildlich gesagt das
Zertifikat abholen dass sie Übermenschen
sind ja hast du vollkommen recht das ist
wirklich das kommt dann durch die
Arroganz ja dadurch dass beide sich als
was besonderes gesehen haben
heißt er nicht oder das muss ja nicht
heißen dass die dann auch empathisch
sein könnten also ihm fehlt ja völlig
diese diese völliges ich habe überhaupt
keine Empathie als zumindest nicht für
Leute die die für ihr in ihren Augen
irgendwie nicht lebenswert sind dadurch
dass sie wenn du dich zum Übermenschen
machst degradierst du ja automatisch
die anderen die andere Klasse die
anderen Menschen die ihm deiner Meinung
nach nicht zu den Übermenschen gehören
und sicherlich hätten sie das Bedürfnis
gehabt dass er das irgendwann mal
erzählen um einfach sich natürlich den
den Ruhm dafür den Anführungszeichen
Ruhm dafür abzuholen aber Gott sei Dank
ist es nicht so weit gekommen und die
Ansicht des Übermenschen ist das Gott
sei Dank
zu Staub zerfallen ja und wie gefährlich
dieses Konstrukt dass das haben wir ja
geschichtlich auch schon
ähm ich bin sehr froh dass die beiden so
doof waren und die Brille da verloren
haben weil wer weiß wenn die schon so
früh so viel von sich halten und einen
Mord als Bestätigung ihrer Intelligenz
und ihre ihre übermenschlichkeit sehen
dann will ich nicht wissen was die
eventuell sonst noch alles ausgeheckt
hätten bringt uns zur abschließenden
Frage gibt es das perfekte Verbrechen
hoffentlich nicht
machen wir uns nicht weiter Gedanken um
das perfekte Verbrechen das war das war
schon genug Mord und Totschlag für heute
vielen Dank fürs Zuhören wir haben
diesen Podcast vorbereitet mit einem
Artikel der Universität von Missouri der
ZDF history Doku das perfekte Verbrechen
einem Online-Beitrag des DLF und der
Seite Criminal Minds Redaktion und
Skript Stefan netzebart Aufnahme und
schnitt Antonia Heier brustproduktion
durch Wake world München hoffentlich bis
zum nächsten Mal also morgen eure Toni
und euer Mirko